i don't think you get it bro
as you were reading that i could see it
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
guys
it's your monday fun day you know the
vibes guys you know the vibes you know
the drill yeah um
once again
if you get to the end of this episode
and you're thinking to yourself that was
good but i need more i can't be asked to
wait till next week
how about three days head on over to
patreon.com
meet the real james and foohad yeah mom
connect with us deeply deeply you get
your extra episode every week you're
gonna get exclusive access to us via the
comments and the dms and the community
that we got going over there um you get
first dibs on all topic suggestions and
am i the [ __ ] and friend requests
um
and if you're feeling cheeky you'll get
invited to have a zoom meeting with us
true every month
say a meeting it's more of a
collaboration
[Music]
collaboration of like-minded minds all
together to get to know each other and
have some fun
uh it's only gonna cost you three pound
a month okay
bit more if you're feeling cheeky but
let's just start basic three pound a
month 10p a day run the p you know what
it is as patreon.com forward slash shits
and gigs head on over there now and then
come back while you're here
like the video subscribe to the channel
two fingers of death hit that
notification bell
so you make sure you know when we're
we're topping up when we're moving fast
you want to keep up okay
uh we can't wait for you guys
and uh as always guys chirps a ting in
the comments it's been happening these
past couple of weeks it's been boogie
we've been seeing it don't worry guys
we're out there man shooting shots and
we're receiving so we love to see it
keep it coming everyone needs to get a
chirps yeah everyone needs to hold the
chirps exactly head on into them
comments chirps a couple things um and
enjoy the rest of the video i guess i
hope you guys had a good christmas
um hope you guys got what you wanted
hope you
secured the manscaped as well couple
merch as well as you can see we're
rocking well i'm rocking the sng one
um
yeah man
hopefully new year's is around the
corner you guys gonna celebrate well we
asked you guys in the comments or we
asked you guys in the video last week um
what your new year's resolution is going
to be hopefully you guys stick to it i
was on patreon was it on patreon uh you
guys have to sign into that one yeah
but yeah man um
that's the intro done for the week and
let's get into the
the fluff of her i've not done a fun
fact in a minute you haven't i feel like
i'm missing out on them
i'm ready i'm ready i'm ready
right um which one should i do
okay
a man receives a six million dollar
offer jury
a man receives six million after jury
discovers detective made up the whole
story that led to him serving 23 years
in prison
so okay
okay
i'm ready fam
i've never read the whole thing i read
that bit first and i was like wow
and also this was sent to me by um a
fandom as well oh sick extra gang all
right let's go
um in 1995 daryl howard was found guilty
of murder and arson in deaths of doris
washington 29 and her 13 year old
daughter nashonda in 1991.
he was handed an 80-year
prison sentence but his sentence was cut
short when a durham county judge
exonerated him in 2016
citing prosecutional misconduct and new
dna evidence
a year later he filed for federal civil
rights lawsuit against daryl dowdy
accusing the former durham detective and
others
if there's days in this
there's ds in this i'm i'm sarah daryl
doris dowdy
fab how do you think i feel
there's d's in this every time you say a
new d it throws me off off the case
that's what they do on purpose go on
we say that again um
a year later he filed for federal civil
rights lawsuit against daryl dowdy
accusing a former durham detective and
others of making up the story which led
to his sentence dowdy then became the
sole defendant in this in this suit and
was found to have fabricated evidence
over the course of the investigation
around after a year washington and his
shonda were killed dowdy shared details
of the case with angela oliver a sex
worker and a drug addict with mental
health issues
in an earlier recording played during
the 1995 trial oliver claimed she would
she'd seen howard assault washington and
take her upstairs and later she had had
burns on her bodies despite no physical
evidence linking into the scene
in august this year
she recanted the statement in a
deposition in a deposition after and
after revealed dowdy kosher on what to
say
both the tape and dowdy's notes on the
case were nowhere to be found
nick bruston an attorney from howard
said
i think i think to some extent the
racist defense that we have been
implementing since the beginning of the
litigation or legation rather has in
some way succeeded
i think the verdict doesn't value the
suffering that daryl went through though
which is obviously fair enough
fam they fabricated the whole thing
twenty so he even got a prozzie on board
to roll
to make up some stuff as well they made
up the whole thing imagine being in
court
for something that you did not do that
you had no connection with
and then all of a sudden all of a sudden
some random crackhead prostitute rocks
up to the stand and says yeah my man
this man you've never seen her before
big man my world will be wrong oh you'll
be spinning because you obviously and
you can't in the courtroom you can't
lash out you can't just [ __ ]
who's this [ __ ]
who is this being mama we tell you to
calm down i'm gonna have to eject you
yeah
we can wrap this up if you're gonna keep
screaming like that we can wrap this up
now
right you have to hold your tongue i'll
say who is this shaking brother
what did i do
six million dollars is not enough oh
it's not enough bro nowhere near enough
nowhere near i mean he'll live lavish
with it but it's never near enough 23
years did you say
nah bro 20. how to be fair though how
many because i'm sure they're man from
thing you've got more than that which
man um what was that show that was on
netflix that's a true story about the
kids that all got
put in pen for murder in new york
five black kids
um
when they see us
when they see us i'm sure
their payout was like over a hundred
yeah their payout was disgusting
obviously between the five of them was
disgusting
i can't remember how much but it was
disgusting but they they spent time in
bed
so did he spend time yeah to be fair so
did he say i don't really know he spent
more time than that yeah for sure for
sure for sure and i'm pretty sure
his sounds even worse than the [ __ ]
what they went through
i think it's because of the fact that
actually no does it sound worse because
i just remembered the reason why the
other guy those five kids went to jail
obviously have you seen you've seen it
right yeah yeah the park situation and
blah blah blah
damn that was a show but yeah that was
an amazing show yeah wow that's probably
top five shows i've seen on there yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that was
amazing bro yeah yeah yeah yeah i was i
was i was mad at the world when i
watched that same i was mad at that i
wanted vengeance for no reason for every
reason but no none at all yeah
me some of that money because i feel
this
i feel like yes yeah but it's all of us
run me some of those reparations oh bro
ah it took it took side at me
when i watched that it was it was tough
it was actually really really harsh but
yeah that pair was fat yeah disgusting i
can't remember how much it was but it
was in the tens of millions for sure do
you remember the scene where um
the
the light skin that the half mexican don
yes was getting
bullied by his stepmom
like she must have tried chat [ __ ] to
him
and he must have said something and she
would come out after him like i'm not
gonna have some [ __ ] murder or talk
to me like that in my house i think i
remember and his dad was the only one i
was riding for him i think her it
doesn't
no it's a tough one
but i remember his dad was the only one
riding for him
[Music]
and his dad's missus was not about it i
don't remember that scene that much it
was [ __ ] peak but i think it sounds
it [ __ ] know it sounds it's not
because obviously man's done his time
yeah he's done everything yeah he's
trying to come out yeah yeah yeah and he
started dealing drugs because he
couldn't get job couldn't get nothing
i remember now i remember now i remember
the drug thing but i don't remember
i remember now it rings it's coming back
now it's all coming back to me so all
coming back to me it's all coming back
to me yeah yeah bro
i'm not gonna have some [ __ ] murderer
attack
boxer in her face she was with other
people in the yard yeah i remember yeah
remember now yes i remember now
yeah man yeah i could never have someone
speak to me like that oh that's um they
went through a lot and they went from
hell i'm back i don't think i don't
think i'll be able to find something
like that i don't think my like going to
jail and all that stuff i don't just
don't think i'd be able to survive all
of that no no especially for
doing something
or going in for something i didn't do
for ex let's say i went in for 10 years
and obviously i was uh wrongfully
accused blah blah blah exactly maybe
exactly the same story as his or her
same story as when they see us
i don't think i'd be able to
keep saying i didn't do it oh bro
you know what i mean insane i don't
think i'd be able to do it say 23 years
did it do it big man
i couldn't have mine look at me like
cause you didn't
have my i'll fight everyone oh it'll be
someone it'll be the same [ __ ] different
day i'll be so annoyed and so angry i'm
just eating this gruel like some waste
man you just it's it's nuts it's
actually nuts because that's that's how
people just say okay [ __ ] it i did it
then
literally [ __ ] it i did it then i might
as well say i did it because i'm here
now and they're not letting me out firm
yeah 100
i might as well [ __ ] say i did it bro
and then once you say you've done it you
can't go back
you can't go back once you said you've
done it of course not
of course not nah this system you've
admitted it the system is different
you've admitted it you're mine now mine
you put mine in a box nah bro oh my
goodness nah bro
um yeah that's that's dreadful it is
very dreadful um um it wasn't even a fun
fact it was just a fact yeah there was
nothing fun about it literally nothing
fun about it um it's terrible news
random i'm nippy have you got a spare
hoodie or something
gang
nippy oh yeah
i feel better now
oh thank you sir that's all right um
this is cozy
um
so
we have
the final verdict so guys i don't even
remember a couple of weeks ago we had a
guy and a girl beefing about who's
responsible
for yeah then in the car
for after doggie after a young doggie
dead enough the doggy then and after
doggy um
we had so are we requested that said
said parties parties would give further
evidence to see if we can determine if
homeboy is responsible
um and should have to pay up
or if she should have to pay for our own
dent in our car that that my man need
into it while he was banging her so
they sent in their [ __ ] the same evening
oh really yeah they didn't waste any
time both of them gang so okay cool
so
originally
we received
um
a message from this female saying
i have an ick for men
when you're having car sex and he wants
to do you from behind so he gets his
so he gets his bare pale ass out of the
car in the freezing cold and starts
hitting it from behind whilst putting a
dent in your door with his knee
icky behavior
we then
found that bear pale ass stung
she was
she went for the judge she was so pissed
off
anyway right so then
a couple days later we received another
message from a gentleman saying am i the
[ __ ] i was beating out this girl
doggy in her car and ended up denting
her car door with my knee smashing
against it
she wants me to pay for the dent i said
nah
she washes the pod so tell her man ain't
paying cool
so we we we we sent out a request for
further information
um and let me just find it because we
received both from both parties
so we started with the female so let's
finish with her as well
guys let's take a very quick break to
shed some love on the boys over at man
escaped you know what it is you know
what they do christmas is out the way
it's trying it's time to get your [ __ ]
back together okay
right so we'll start off from the top
and work our way down okay so the best
selling product that man's gate have to
offer is their performance package 4.0
which is at the top of every man's wish
this list okay the wish list this year
sorry
inside this performance package you've
got the lawnmower we already know what
that does led lights
rapids
technology does exactly what it says on
the tin waterproof everything best
trimmer on the market it's helped some
four million men just saying
um are we responsible for half
technically yes
technically yes yeah we are um and then
we've got the famous liquid formulations
you've got your crop preserver ball
deodorant and the crop reviver that
toner that's silver you heard about move
yeah you didn't even know what the words
mean brother if i didn't know these
things exist yeah yeah yeah bull toner
and reviver nah now you don't live like
this
that fresh fresh feeling yeah man
you already know it's moving
and to top it off you get the free gifts
you get the elite
textured
travel bag
executive
supreme battery supreme and then you get
that soft soft silky smooth boxes
that latex feel that bro it just slides
on it it slides on slides on slides off
it's it's just feel good it's a feel
good factor it's a feel good factor so
don't let your pubes get in the way
head on over to landscape.com the code
is sng you're gonna get yourself golf
sierra november golf you're gonna get
yourself a young 20 off and free
shipping worldwide manuscript.com sng
free shipping 20 off let's get back to
the episode here we go
so we wanted to know what kind of energy
she was bringing
to determine if he said he ain't paying
as a defense mechanism yeah yeah which
is
you assumed don't mind indicating
it was a defense team all right cool so
she said the deed was done all was well
until he pulled up his shorts to cover
his pasty ass
when he then mumbled the words oh [ __ ]
there's a dent
pasty ass it's not fair she's just not
um oh [ __ ] there's a dent
we then evaluated the situation at hand
and both agreed it was more than a dent
at this point i was furious
in brackets i mean the sex weren't even
that great
so i politely asked
politely asked
if there's any way he could pay for it
in brackets bear in mind we had to use
my car as he don't even have a driving
license
he straight up bluntly said nabi i ain't
paying for that that's a you problem
he's been listening to you too much
that's something you'd [ __ ] say
therefore he's the [ __ ] in the
situation as i'm a broke [ __ ] who now
has to pay 250 pounds for a dent in the
side of my car for some half decent
doggy sesh
[ __ ] so her argument points were
it was his
his idea to get out and bang it from
behind he then didn't at the car he
discovered the dent
she supposedly politely asked
can you help pay for this
and he said nabi that's a you problem
she put it in quotations so something
tells me that potentially is definitely
what he said
navi that's a you problem
i mean
we just have to take those facts as
facts we have to yeah we have to take
those facts we can't assume anyone's
lying we have to take it as said we both
offered
um
they've both been given the opportunity
to explain themselves
so if
so for example if he then comes back now
and says nah she didn't say that then
that's a different discussion but then
if he doesn't even reference that then
we have to take hers as yeah
as fact it definitely happened all right
cool so
let's have a look see
uh i said i just watched the episode
i said nah i'm not having her come for
my pale ass
she said i'll pay for the door if she
pays for my spray tan if my ass is so
pasty wow
also
okay
also couldn't have given her that much
of an ick if she came back for round two
next week
[Music]
we'll discuss if that's relevant to the
case or not hmm
it's not relevant to this specific case
but it's relevant it is relevant okay
also man six five car sex don't run in a
small car
uh
again semi-relevant but that's your
business
um
so i had to be back shots and didn't
even clock until i went to pull my
drawers back up that i've been trying
the door with the knee so that that that
correlates with what she said yeah yeah
yeah yeah pulled the drawers up and then
they discovered the dent we then spoke
about it and she was big mad but what
can you do the game is the game
okay
okay tell her i'll run the ps
if you man deem me responsible the deal
the the ball is in the judges court now
p.s asks if she wants round three
i was waiting for satisfied
um
okay
so
his rebuttal
is that um
he he's too big to be having car sex had
to get out
so basically he's saying he did do it
did do it he did do it he's acknowledged
that he's done it she's acknowledged
that he's done it and his thing was
the game is the game
so her okay so her argument is
you didn't end up my door trying to
backshot me
and you said when i asked you to pay you
said nabi that's a you problem and his
argument is he doesn't even have an
argument he just said the game's the
game it's the game there is no argument
there is no argument but he'll pay if
she pays for his spray tan to spray his
pasty ass
i'll let i'll let i'll let you see i'll
i'll let you decide
rain it's um it's funny that
we'll take the non-relevant bit first
and we'll come back to the relative bit
irrelevant bit rather so the
non-relevant bit was
um
how she came back for seconds the week
after yes
so darling
right
you were cussing him with his white pace
diaz this that any other in week one
we understand
that he said he wasn't going to write
you the p then you were heated you saw
the dead
yeah the idea that words are exchanged
but a week later you still want to bang
him
now he's you have said he hasn't got a
driver's license so
you have a [ __ ] in yards or clearly
[ __ ] in a car
he can't [ __ ] the guy he's six-five
that's a big guy
he has to dog you
so understandably if you're mad at
someone about someone that's not giving
you something i either pee why are you
seeing him again yeah so that is a big
factor in that
i was
even though he said it wasn't relevant
i'm one million percent on her side
apart from the fact that she won't see
him again that she
went to get piped again by my man
even though she supposedly now considers
him a walking ick
and she said the dick wasn't even that
good and she said yeah it was half
decent
so she went back again and he's asking
round three round three what is it three
people what are you saying
but nevertheless um i think i think
homeboy is right you should you should
pay for the ting i'm talking to my man
by the way you should pay for the team
considering both stories kind of line up
like no one's out clearly no one's
chatting [ __ ] no one's telling a lie
within the same ref he's owned up to his
mistake he said you know what i'll pay
free if you pay for my spray tan on
around three
i feel like that's the
that's the easiest way to go about it
yeah run homeboy a spray tan and um the
debt is is the debt is resolved resolved
literally i guess it's resolved but
within the same breath women women love
to
when they're inconvenienced
they would like for eggs for example
they go for the jugular yeah yeah they
go for the jugular 100 this white paper
what's my ass got to do with it nothing
this mask got to do with it big had
nothing to do with it
because
if
the guy sent something in and was like i
was banging this chick in the car she
had fat titties with nice arse but
something let's say for example she had
a massive forehead and he put that in it
was [ __ ] irrelevant that's irrelevant
why are you waiting for her it's [ __ ]
irrelevant yeah
you're sending it for his ass yes he did
something wrong like he [ __ ] up your
car but
these aren't they don't weigh up they
don't that is none
yeah yeah girls when they when they are
inconvenienced they will send for any
ammo that they can use for ammo it's not
on it's officially let's stick to the
point at hand yeah for real
um okay
one thing i will say though on her in
her defense
homeboy
granted um he said his piece he seems
open and honest to say okay if the judge
is deemed it necessary etc
but if it is true that she said can you
help me pay for this and he said now b
that's a you problem he's a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
he's a [ __ ]
he's not a man yeah that's not man
behavior don't talk like that especially
after busted nuts
united and i said nah baby that's that's
you that's you
but what's even worse obviously yes this
has happened this is what he has said
and he's confirmed he said this she
piped him the week off oh yeah of course
i'm not i'm fam i'm not on her side of
this there's
no i'm just i'm not arguing with your
point i'm just saying it's baffling to
me oh she's dumb it's baffling to me
i don't know where they live and i think
i've seen the girl she ain't ugly
so i don't know if they live in a
village yeah or what's going on i don't
know what's going on
because let me see this chick oh okay
yeah is she cute man cute yeah and
you can get different dick i don't
understand why you would see my man
again because you get now you put the
water power in his court you have if we
didn't have this discussion
now there's no way he's paying it yeah
yeah yeah yeah cause he knows now he can
mug you off to your face
and you're still gonna roll through
there's you you can't empower that
behavior yeah you're still gonna suck
him off next week yeah it's not fair
that's just not fair on you or him fast
it's not fair on you or him or any lady
that comes after you because now he
thinks he's the dogs exactly
oh my goodness so i'm told to sort our
[ __ ] car after she came back next
week got banged again nah fam
nah firm and all you can do is send for
his payload in the dms you need to cut
him off no lock it lock it lock it yeah
but homeboy um you're gonna have to pay
you have to pay you're gonna have to pay
there's no way that you can dent up a
yacht's car and then when she asks you
to pay you say now be that's you
probably you're gonna have to pay yeah
yeah you're gonna have to pay you can't
that can't run none of all that we don't
yeah that yeah yeah
even even if you can't pay the whole
thing speak to one you're gonna have to
contribute
one two five that's all it takes yeah
you're gonna have two fifty one two five
even if it's a a monthly standing order
thing
sorry to contribute somehow you have to
you know
you're amazing i don't know whatever
you're gonna do but do it
do it yeah bro you can't be telling man
that's a you problem
no you physically did it just you
literally just you did this
and i said nah nah that's cold
brother that's cold he must have been
shattered yeah that that's true as well
what are you doing that's because
obviously when we spoke if i hit it
twice on the same spot on the on the
cusp of the patella same the skin's thin
there as well i would feel it i'm
stopping the whole activity you hear me
oh man she'll probably look like oh yeah
yeah i'm never feeling it
[Laughter]
she's thinking oh
that's for the bus i think nah man
my knees could have passed my knee yeah
i don't know what he was on time but
dead in someone's car not even now was
know what's going on the puss must have
been engulfing him
like a what what's the word i'm looking
for like a [ __ ] uh what's that warp
thing
uh
black hole that's the one it was black
hole yeah fam his eyes were rolled back
man didn't even know he was puncturing
metal how did you not even it must have
been like a ford ka or something yeah
yeah some flimsy aluminium in the car
because i'll feel that on the second
yeah 500. 100 for 500. oh no but fair
play yeah gee that's the the the course
i've decided you're gonna have to free
up the yeah free up the p pay for all up
here for some negotiate talk to her and
hopefully try and get that third back
yeah if you get the third bang as well
that's even better that's
everyone's calm now everyone's happy
everyone's happy clearly yeah that's how
i know the puzzles in gotham because he
said
yeah
for your skin tone
on soulja boy's internet and you still
messaged saying is she down for another
one you know that person's engulfing you
you know that person
wasn't tight
that's a bit tight
you accept abuse yeah that promise has
got you acting differently yeah
chokehold yeah
[ __ ] chokehold poor guy it's a shame
right i have got
more
twitter hall of fame
hmm
right i'm going to need to ready myself
for this because last time was
i can't see you sweat like that again
i can't see you sweat like that again
all right
last time yeah that also versus the
pizza ting had me bossing up for about
an hour
you [ __ ] go
it was that one
from the greed and the bible the bbl
table yeah that's the green they talk
about the bible
it had me bro [ __ ] up all right but
i sp i kind of forget this out i spilled
baked beans all over myself watching
cars 2 in the theaters and a black
teenager just shouted this [ __ ] eating
baked beans and everyone
[Laughter]
i don't think you get it bro
as you were reading that i could see it
[Music]
[Laughter]
[ __ ] sake
[ __ ] i can't breathe i'm sweating
already
we're off to the races
[ __ ] eating baked beans bro bro why
are you eating baked beans in the cinema
so many plot holes oh
my abs i couldn't have someone expose me
like that
shouting in the thing i mean i said
everyone laughed
this
big
no no
no
[ __ ] that's funny
no oh it's made my head hurt oh i'm
actually sweating again
jesus christ all right let's move on
let's be honest
you can't force me to be a present
father it's my body
[ __ ] sake
[ __ ] sake he's man bruv oh
you're a [ __ ] if you grew up with a
father because that means for at least a
decade of your life you're calling
another [ __ ]
oh bro people are idiots man people are
actually is he here
you're a [ __ ] if you ever planned a
fight with another [ __ ] because that
means you're playing you're making plans
with a [ __ ] and that's gay
now twitter's i'm telling you twitter is
the funniest place and it's got me
sweating james you're sweating again the
creases in your neck are wet again from
i'm putting this fan on [ __ ] it oh i'm
sorry team right
let me catch my [ __ ] breath
being with the little dick man is is
terrible because when you have a son
then their dick is the same size you're
changing diapers mad as hell this is why
they don't want to [ __ ] you after the
baby's born
i can't even laugh about that family
that's painful
am i just looking at your baby's tool
i'm thinking that's the same as your
dad's
nah
that's pete a [ __ ] was in my bed 72
hours ago and now he's on one knee
asking for someone's hand in marriage to
wild times
oh wow someone replied to that saying
that's what bad [ __ ] will do for you
oh wow fam right that's actually to be
fair
bummy puss
bummy puss will send you back to your
misses
immediately
once you've knotted oh you oh you're
you're shivering with shame
i want to than i'll snap myself out of
there
i want to get the [ __ ] out of there
bro
that's hilarious bummy ass puss will
send you packing bro
some stinky stubbly ass
kitty cat
that's it back in the day bro that sent
me yard
and you you want to apologize for
nothing because obviously you're just
walking the car communicate you just
shake and hold
i said let's go to bed
it's only 8 p.m baby bam and you just
want to weep oh my goodness oh man said
i'll serve cracker before i serve this
country
no
oh i asked this lady can i touch your
hair she said yes so i ran my fingers
across the top lip and that's how the
fight started
[Laughter]
yo
someone doing that to you
can i touch your hair yeah and they just
cute
i can tell i can tell for a fact
if the yacht was black
she's throwing hay makers
hands brother
connecting to jawlines bro oh
my chest oh [ __ ] that's funny
ah homophobia homophobia is dumb
why are you mad that another guy is
getting [ __ ] down it sounds like
jealousy to me
oh fair enough it's facts
imagine coming home to your girl in bed
you tell her a joke then boom the [ __ ]
under the bed starts laughing too
[Laughter]
no
oh bro my head's getting hot i'm getting
a headache it doesn't make sense i'm
getting a pressure headache
oh
to the men who held me at gunpoint on
63rd and king drive and made me nae nae
you're a bunch of cowards
[Laughter]
a man said he had to do this with
survival
you bunch of cowards
that's a movie ting fan [ __ ]
stop stop
stop
yo
oh i don't think i understand the pain
in my skull right now bro
oh you're a bunch of cowards oh my god
from what life are we living what life
are we living
oh [ __ ]
how judges be sleeping at night after
giving a [ __ ] 40 years
stop
stop
stop stop stop stop
please please please my head
oh
god
[ __ ] with no job should not be able to
get in their girl's car and recline the
seat [ __ ] sit up so you can see who's
hiring
stop stop
oh
[Laughter]
i think that's my second favorite one
apart from the baked beans that's my
second favorite one
oh the baby's had me had me
bro
oh god
oh my god i hate this oh i hate this
episode
i'm gonna save the rest for another day
because please do fam my stomach is done
please do
oh oh jesus christ
sorry guys but yeah we were in a
different world then [ __ ] hell i
didn't know where i was bro i didn't
know where i was
it reminded me of like um
you not on hot ones
yes
when they get to like chicken six and
seven they don't know where they are
spinning they don't know who's asking
what and they don't know what they're
saying
bro that's how i felt then sean's asking
them questions and they can't even
concentrate they're just like hold on
give me milk give me water give me
tissue give me sight i don't i don't
know sean just wait
[ __ ] wait
oh wow that hurt me brother
jesus christ me as well you're eating
baked beans
nah but oh
what i would have given to being in that
screening bro
just behind me i would have shunned the
light on him
i hear you scream behind me this [ __ ]
eating beans
i can never look back and see a grown
man with beans on his top
i would die
fam
i would
die on the spot
that's too funny bro
that's too funny bob
jesus my head is pounding through her
twitter is the funniest place alive guys
it actually is
there's one so thank you for that
ah jesus christ
oh [ __ ] me okay i have gotten on my
[ __ ] but before that yeah i was
adamant i'm not doing x this week okay i
just can't i just need a break i need to
breathe and i need a break okay but one
guy sent in
the funniest thing
i need to find it
one guy owned up and and told us that he
he physically gave
his own mrs the egg oh really
bro so
hang on
also
homeboy sent it in
then re-read the thing messaged and said
i literally just clocked how bad my
spelling and grammar was and sent it
again correct
i have to give him props for it it's a
first it's a first right
title of this message gave my girl the
ick
i went ice skating with the misses i'm
not the best skater but i but i somewhat
know what i'm doing
imagine i was minding my own business
skating close to the edge
when this little [ __ ] of a kid comes out
of nowhere falls and clips my skate
i go down like a sack of [ __ ] but
managed to catch onto the side barrier i
could see it i can see it however whilst
avoiding
to wait however whilst avoiding to
complete fall to the ground wait
let me start in you did it wrong
again how many times are you going to be
right again i might say wait
he smelled wrong again
right however whilst avoiding to
completely fall to the ground yeah i'm
sliding and flapping about like a fish
yeah i look at my girl and just see
disappointment she's just there she's
shaking her head i managed to get back
to my feet and she tells me that i'd
given her the ick and i should have hit
the ground like a man
a lose-lose no sloppy top for me tonight
oh
stress fam stress you can't win with
women you can't you literally
when i read that the first time i could
physically see it
my girl looked at him and said hit the
ground like a grown man
why are you grips in the side
why
why are you letting inanimate objects
hold your weight
if you're going to hit the ground hit
the ground like a man i can imagine his
legs holding the ting i'm sliding
panicking his face looking for his goal
help me
there's no
i'm trying to fight like there's a very
thin line when it comes to the activity
of ice skating
whereas you're either just drying up
[ __ ]
[Music]
or people think you're gay
do you know what i mean there's a very
thin like brother before i agree or
disagree elaborate okay
so you're either trash at skating yes
you either trash a skating yeah and
you're just drying all the vaginas up
yeah
or
you're
decent at skating
but you look ch
you're not a man
you're gliding on ice
like sometimes you're like flying like
because if you're too good yeah the way
you glide is is just it's not it
do you know
it's not butch enough for that man
as soon as you perfect the the crossover
crossover
you slide across like yes yes yes okay a
couple man will get fruit into it
backwards yeah that's when you're a yeah
yeah
come on as soon as you can do the thing
backwards yeah you think i'm sick
you're drying up just as many [ __ ] as
my man that can't hit the floor you need
to be just
good enough yeah to have a power stance
yeah yeah yeah and then you go for like
a quick
a little cut cut skid yeah and then
you're back off the other way yeah then
they think
it looks like he knows what he's doing
yeah yeah yeah as soon as you you hit a
backwards thing and do a crossover that
way yeah
yeah
yeah
um
but yeah okay cool i needed to get that
one off my chest because it made me
laugh you should hit the ground like a
man
no you can't actually win with women
physically gone that's that's evidence
that's evidence
and he was sabotaged he was it wasn't
even his fault it wasn't his fault some
little [ __ ] clipped him and he went down
a peek
all right
can we breathe let's do the mind of the
[ __ ] okay let me drink some water
above
[ __ ] sake
i'm gonna laugh like this in ages bro i
haven't laughed like that in a minute
well tell her like i laughed exactly
that hard last week yeah allows it to be
fair same [ __ ]
oh god
right
i said hi man i hope you he he sent this
to me directly
i don't know why but he did okay
right
i'm gonna premise this or preface this
sorry by saying i'm not as as much as i
appreciate the message from the homeboy
i'm not a fan of this am i the [ __ ]
whatsoever
and
i believe you'll agree with me we'll see
okay okay
so i said hi man i hope you're well
um
i have one for am i the [ __ ]
my friend broke up with his ex and after
a week of being single he started
talking to this girl he says he doesn't
want to be official but he spends every
day at hers
he's now not interested at work if i see
him he's constantly on his phone to her
he's not listened previously previously
to advice and to heal from his breakup
am i the [ __ ] for calling him out and
potentially losing a friend
as it's now impacting my mental health
so
from the sounds of it
he's
his boy broke up with his long-term
girlfriend
he's on some rebounding
gassed off the rebounding says it's
nothing serious but he's chatting to the
thing non-stop he's always with the girl
and then a hop skip and a jump later
it's now affecting my mental health
because i have to see you you you live
this lavish
and he's not listening i'm trying to
advise you you need to heal from your
breakup you need to heal from breakup
and you're like yeah safe sensitive and
then you're just clapping cheeks and
it's [ __ ] you up first for some
reason it's [ __ ] you for some reason
i'm vet
is affecting my mental health that's
that's serious that's some serious hate
raid
fam
you said it that's some serious hate
raid it's sat he sounds like he's green
with envy in my journey that's all it
sounds like to me it sounds like you
feel like you're losing your boy
maybe not green with envy maybe that
could be it as well oh you think he's
jealous of actually not just not having
it yet
no like
losing his boy as a because considering
he's considered he's continuously
linking the [ __ ] banging yeah he's
losing his boy yeah so that's probably
why that's probably another thing but to
say he's it's affecting his mental
health that's that's a hop skip and a
jump fram he leapt to that i was waiting
for an extra paragraph of explanation
like how yeah
how
that's a bit much um i feel like also
people deal with [ __ ] differently like
if he was with his ex and he's using
this thing to get over his ex and let
him do what he needs to do people have
to deal with their [ __ ] in one way or
the other people have to deal with their
[ __ ] one way ever and people also have
to make their own mistakes 100 you can't
you can't be there to make the mistakes
for them they have to learn from their
own mistakes literally like i was this i
was listening to a podcast actually on
the way here
and
basically it was it was a similar topic
in terms of there's
there's nothing i can ever tell you
that's going to be as educational
as the hard
fist [ __ ] life will give you
like if i tell you
big man honestly if you keep talking to
people like that
someone's going to start smacking you up
i can tell you that turn blue in the
face you're going to do what you want to
do until one day someone smacks the
living [ __ ] out of you and then you're
going to listen
you're going to listen to the lesson god
gave [ __ ]
yeah so
it's like you have to make your own
mistakes like people
like how do i explain it like the reason
older people are wiser is because
they've lived through [ __ ] not just
because they just sit down and listen to
everything everyone tells them you
literally have to physically experience
[ __ ]
and like
we've experienced [ __ ] so people like to
ask us obviously what are our advices
and devices yeah but
you still have to experience it you have
to live it and regardless if you think
your boy is [ __ ] up and he should be
doing xyz
like it's let him do his [ __ ] thing
yeah if it was me and you and then you
just went for a tough break up and
you're chatting to this next thing and i
said bro i'm gonna be honest with you i
genuinely think you're using this girl
as a distraction you should probably
focus on
healing or whatever because i don't want
to come and bite you later on down the
road if i didn't say that to you and
then you carry on anyway
i don't give a [ __ ] anymore it is i've
said my piece yeah it's your life it
doesn't affect me whatsoever do what you
want
and i said oh he's not engaged at work
every time i see him
so what
he has to deal with it somehow
he has to deal with it somehow i mean
there's a slight difference if
if it's like a dramatic shift in
behavior so if we were hanging out for
example i can see potentially where it
might be coming from if me and you were
chilling and then now you're actually
acting different
because every 10 minutes you're sending
like soppy voice notes or you're acting
you're actually acting like a waste man
and i actually have to tell you like bro
i don't care
that you're seeing this new girl whether
but you're you're acting different bro
and you're icking me as a boy
i don't want to be around you yeah yeah
then that might be a little bit
different but then again i wouldn't say
that affects my mental health i'll just
say you're acting like a waste man and
then you can take it or leave it
i agree i agree you shouldn't i think
it's a lot to say it's affecting your
mental health but then again you are
allowed to say whatever you want to say
but within the same breath he has to
deal with whatever he has to deal with
if he's if he's making a wrong decision
he actually has to find out
unfortunately let him make that decision
and then learn from it you know
um but yeah i guess that's pretty much
open shot
i think it's pretty open in shot
um
that's it guys i guess
until thursday yeah man for you guys
that haven't subscribed
sign up to the patreon full slash and
gigs every thursday you get that new
exclusive
raw
honest opinions of us
on there and we can go from there mum
yeah man thank you guys for sticking
around um
i love you in it
i love you that's what i have to say i
[ __ ] said it i love you bro
um i know i understand half of that
episode was just us laughing
so apologies if that was not what you
came for
but yeah again guys thank you so much
for taking the time to stick with us
thank you so much for continuing to um
send us in your the [ __ ] i have no
idea if this is going to be the last
episode before the new year or not
um
i think it no it's
youtube wise yes patreon wise now
cool well guys
um
we hope you had a great christmas have
an awesome new year we're going to see
you on the other side yeah we've got big
things popping coming in 2022 yeah and
we're really excited to share it with
you
um but yeah liv lavish
tell us what you get up to on your new
year's eve i'm sure there's going to be
plenty of gossip coming our way can't
wait for that can't wait for that yeah
man so uh provided the dancers are still
open yeah uh depending on the customer
yeah hopefully we won't go into another
lockdown but guys
enjoy and um yeah man let's just wrap it
[Music]
up you